bonjour marine biseau merci de répondre
à nos questions en direct sur arte
france avant toute chose comment est-ce
que vous réagissez au fait qu'un premier
médecin hospitalier en france
viennent de succomber aux coronavirus ça
nous fait peur c'est sûr que de toute
façon à la tous les soignants sont sur
le front
c'est vrai qu'on a bien mesurer
l'ampleur de la situation et on est tous
conscients en fait de notre
responsabilité de soignants les les
pompiers continueront feu ils ont une
tonitruante les soldats quand ils
partent faire la guerre ils ont des
casques les policiers quand ils partent
en opération il m'aidait gilet
pare-balles et nouba l'approbation les
soignants n'a pas suffisamment de
masques se préparer à protéger les
résidents justement comment est ce que
vous vous préparez dans votre maison de
retraite
quelles sont les mesures qui ont été
prises localement chez vous moi ça fait
depuis fin février début mars cons et
qu'on se prépare à cette crise alors on
a répliqué continue gouvernement très
strictement
on a fermé toutes nos visites depuis
deux semaines déjà à l'extérieur souvent
sont stoppés et on a pris le maximum de
mesures barrières et chaque jour en
réunion on décide de les renforcer de
plus en plus voilà les mesures barrières
les soignants les connaissent tous
personnels travaillant n'est pas de
l'est connaissent ils sont formés pour
et les maîtrisent parfaitement
d'ailleurs pour l'instant notre
établissement nous est préservé et donc
c'est bien une preuve aussi de
l'efficacité de ces mesures barrières et
que quand les maîtrises pour l'instant
malgré tout on sait très bien que les
mesures barrières sans le masque ne sont
pas totale les mesures barrière se laver
les mains et etc
c'est ce n'est qu'à 50 % les 50%
restants s'il nous faut les masques pour
voir il mettre en oeuvre de manière
complète justement on a beaucoup parlé
de la pénurie de masques il hier il ya
eu un olivier viron qui a pris la parole
le ministre de la santé il a annoncé la
commande de 250 millions de masques pour
les jours à venir
qu'est ce que vous espérez vous par
rapport à ce matériel alors nous la
réponse enfin nous la dotation qu'on
sait qu'on va avoir c'est normalement
cinq masques par résident et par semaine
donc sachant que normalement un masque
vous devez changer toutes les quatre
heures sachant que normalement il faut
aussi le changer à chaque fois que vous
sortez d'une chambre si c'est le
soignant qui le porte
donc en fait vous pouvez faire un calcul
c'est un peu une équation impossible
on sait qu'on en aura pas assez donc il
va falloir qu'on fasse
est-ce qu'on adapte ses précautions qui
sont normalement des précautions de base
va faire qu'on les adore ce qu'on fait
des calculs et qu'on s'assoit à nous en
fait de faire des choix et des choix qui
sont à prendre au niveau éthique et
thérapeutiques mais il va falloir qu'on
va devoir restreindre toutes les
utilisations la province en fait on a
consignes qu'on avait avant cette
nouvelle consigne du gouvernement
c'était de lui n'était utilisé que dans
les cas confirmés
finalement c'est un peu tard un bon 10
dans le processus dans une lettre
les principales fédérations du secteur
ont alerté vendredi le ministre de la
santé sur un chiffre elles craignent
cent mille morts du côté de 19 dans les
maisons de retraite est ce que vous
partagez cet avis oui tout à fait
évidemment en fait on vit quand même à
confondre un confinement collectif
ici vous êtes dans une maison de
retraite où il ya 83 résidents donc vous
imaginez bien que si ça rentre c'est
quand même compliqué en fait de d'éviter
que ça ne touche tout le monde
alors on a sectorisé étage par étage et
on mélange plus les résidents des tâches
par étage avant on faisait beaucoup de
vie sociale d'animation etc
maintenant on a là on a arrêté pour
autant on n'est pas encore confiné à
confiner les résidents les chambres
parce qu'il faut quand même aussi qu'ils
puissent avoir un minimum de vie etc des
raisons qui ont qui souffre quand même
beaucoup de l'absence de leur famille
etc
donc voilà et c'est vrai que c'est des
gens qui sont fragiles
si l'on sait très bien on est tous très
lucide là dessus les soignants à ce
travail en ehpad est d'ailleurs à
domicile c'est pareil pour les
personnages et si le virus rentrer en
fait effectivement ça va être une et
gasmi merci marine miso d'avoir répondu
à nos questions je rappelle que vous
êtes directrice adjointe à la maison de
retraite gourlay bon temps dans le val
de marne